what makes your view more important than
the British people when it comes to the
EU and then in out referendum where is
the life out there it's actually Alicia
sure Alicia Alicia a t-shirt um it's
about leadership Alicia it's about
leadership and what I want to achieve as
Prime Minister
look when I look at the country what do
I think the biggest problems in the
country are I think five years of wages
falling behind bills and the threats
going to happen again I think five years
of young people think they're gonna have
a worse life than their parents and five
years of an NHS in crisis and if I'm
Prime Minister in seven or eight days
time I want to spend all of my energies
on those issues not on deciding whether
we want to exit the European Union which
I think Frankie will be a disaster for
the good suppose another voice says your
views more important than mine and
everybody else here
well it isn't I do a Dumas I do respect
that point of view but I don't agree
with it because I'm putting my view
forward and I think one of the things
you've got dem nettles four hours I want
well you do at the general election and
one of the things about leadership
you don't always do what the polls tell
you to do you do what you think is the
right thing for the country
and I've got to level with you and level
with the country but I don't think the
right thing for our country to do now is
to plunge ourselves into two years of
debating whether to leave the EU when
I've got to tell you that for jobs and
the millions of jobs that depend on it
for businesses and for families will be
a disaster
now there's one thing I will say to you
which is there any further transfer of
powers from Britain to the European
Union we would have a referendum I think
unlikely to happen though so you know in
a way you've got to make your own
judgment about what is the most
important issue to you for me it isn't
try get out of the EU